on termine avec la solitaire du figaro
une cinquantaine de régatier se sont
élancés à 12h06 de ouistreham mettant le
cap sur portsmouth en angleterre c'est
la 35e édition de cette course où l'on a
vu éclore les carrières de grands
champions des maire serge bien il est
12h30 quand 52 navigateurs plein
d'espoir s'élance pour la première des
quatre étapes de la solitaire la course
les mènera en angleterre en vendée en
espagne arrivé le 13 août à qui bon
favori
armel le cléac'h le vainqueur de l'an
passé les marins naviguent sur des
bateaux identiques ils doivent gérer le
sommeil composer avec la météo
j'ai gardé une bonne très bonne image de
la course parce que c'est
c'est fantastique oicv heures bord à
bord avec les autres c'est une course de
nerfs dans le petit temps à la moindre
petite erreur d'un compère tout de suite
la sanction tombe immédiatement donc
c'est vraiment très intense en 88
bourgnon de vence gauthier deuxième puis
vainqueurs l'année suivante et naufragés
en 96 est tombé à l'eau personne n'a su
jusqu'au moment où je suis passé sur sa
route
je suis passé sur le quasiment failli
marcher dessus avec mon bateau et il est
monté à bord de mon bateau et depuis on
est devenus amis et surtout c'est lui
qui m'a prêté son bateau pour venir le
figaro les plus grands marquent de leur
empreinte cette épreuve née en 1970
comme philippe poupon jean le cam
s'impose trois fois double vainqueur
michel desjoyeaux ya fait ses armes
avant de repousser l'horizon pour
triompher dans le vendée globe le tour
du monde en solitaire